in the streets of spanair provence the
real city enough in expected to
evidence them event transform
individual works bart de wever in a
way world's largest open air mission
but at least it is project tunick the
complicated team declared
[Music]
my name is o whose sanmiguel I dedicate myself
to  transforming spaces around the world,
especially changing gray cement into
color
the fact of painting and helping me
paint a mural suddenly many have
learned to communicate through
naïve art the wonder you can bring that
century is going to heal it is big to fit in
defense of the worst
[Music]
and transform it into a kind of
universal church where everyone
has a place all religions
all genders for all reasons reward
external structure and we will exhibit tents
the most important thing for me about this project
is the personal experience that I take with me
especially because making art is very
good, art is really transmitting
feelings or sensations to people or
s  It's the technique of making people feel, but if it
changes the life of someone who is
only one, I think that's already a higher level
[Music]